- What do you guys want in
an entrepreneur coffee shop?
(tango music)
(motorcycle engine)
Happy weekend everybody.
Hope you've been having an amazing one.
Nina's happy.
One of the things that
I've been thinking about
is starting an entrepreneur cafe.
A destination place for
entrepreneurs to come to
and work and be surrounded
by an amazing environment.
Where there's entrepreneur
videos happening,
and business plans to look at,
and quotes on the wall,
and stories.
And just a home for entrepreneurs
to work at so we don't
just have to go to, you know, a Starbucks.
I like Starbucks,
but a real place for entrepreneurs.
And so, part of our plan here is,
I want to check out different independent
coffee shops here in Toronto
to get a sense of what they're doing
that might be different
than going to a chain store.
Maybe get some inspiration
for my future coffee shop.
Check it out "Believe".
We're off to a good start.
Here we are.
Sam James Coffee Bar.
I'm back on the street now.
They don't have a bathroom.
Nina needs to go to the bathroom.
So we have to find some place to
go to the bathroom,
so we can go back and have some coffee.
So, first lesson in having my own cafe,
is we need make sure there
is bathrooms close by.
Check.
Bathrooms.
(upbeat music)
Success.
Nina feels
- Better.
- All restaurants should have a bathroom.
- It was a cafe.
- Well, cafe's a type of restaurant.
- Nina's feeling happier.
Her bladder is empty.
Ready to fill it up with some liquid now.
Alright, here we go.
Take two.
(upbeat music)
- Nina's getting a cappuccino.
I'm getting the chai latte.
Oh, and a butter croissant.
- And a croissant.
- And a butter croissant.
She's excited.
This is it.
This is what Nina's going to eat.
Yummy yummy yummy.
Nina's filming for her
YouTube channel too.
We're filming each other, this is what we
do on the weekends.
(laughing)
Go check out Nina's channel.
It's got hearts.
Just like you.
Love.
I got a chai latte.
Nina wants my reaction first.
Chai latte.
Very creamy.
Try it.
No, I don't think it needs it.
Try. Try.
Stop filming yourself.
Try.
It's good.
Some froth on the top.
- Very strong.
- [Evan] Strong?
- Yeah.
- [Evan] You want some sugar?
- [Nina] No, it's okay.
- [Evan] I like the design.
- [Nina] I like it without sugar.
Alright, what do we think Nina?
- Uh, It's just okay.
- Just okay? We need details.
- They don't have bathrooms.
- No bathrooms.
- The staff was not very nice.
- Right?
- They don't smile at us,
- At all. They don't smile.
I feel like the main person
does not know how to smile.
That's a not great first introduction.
Okay, we need friendly staff at our place.
Friendly staff and washrooms, okay?
Next.
- Yeah and need to be more comfortable.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- It's this big bench that
everybody just sits on.
There's no tables.
There's no Wifi.
- Yeah.
- No wifi. Nowhere to like,
it's weird leaning back.
- Yeah.
- Uncomfortable.
You can't really stay there.
It's like a take-out place almost.
- Yeah.
- Okay. What else?
- It's a very boring place.
- Boring.
- Yes, it's just a plain white wall.
- Yeah, we need more
inspiration on ours, okay?
- And the lights are just ...
- Not great?
- Yeah.
- It had natural light.
That was good.
I like the natural light.
Got some good windows.
Fun to be on a main street
and kind of look out
and see what's going on.
That was good.
The music was not great.
- Oh yeah.
- Hard rock.
I guess it fits an audience.
What's entrepreneur music?
Better figure that out.
We need some good entrepreneur music.
Pros, the natural light was good.
The coffee, mine was okay.
- Uh, yeah.
- It was decent.
It wasn't bad.
- I like the heart.
- The display was nice.
Okay, anything else?
Cash only.
Holy cow.
Constantly bothers me.
I might walk out of a cash only place.
Anyway, my place will not be cash only.
Pay however you want to pay.
Alright. That's it.
Guys, we need to hear from you.
What do you want in an entrepreneur cafe?
Leave it in the comments below
and I just might make it happen for you.
We hope you had a great weekend.
We believe in you.
We hope you continue
to believe in yourself
and whatever your
No, you go to point to the camera.
Your
one word is
much love.
We'll see you soon.